you know that the best way to prevent
the spread of coronavirus is to wash
your hands wash your hands but why it's
because soap regular soap fancy
honeysuckle soap artisan peppermint soap
just any soap absolutely annihilates
viruses like the corona virus here's how
this is what a virus like corona virus
looks like it's a bit of material
surrounded by a coating of proteins and
fat virus has easily sticked to places
like your hands but when you rinse your
hands with just water it rushes right
over the virus that's because that layer
of fat makes the virus behave kind of
like a drop of oil you can see it
happening in this demonstration oils are
just liquid fats what happens when you
pour oil into water it floats it doesn't
mix but adds soap and suddenly that
fatty oil dissolves into the water
that's because inside soap has two sided
molecules one end of the molecule is
attracted to water the other end to fat
so when the soap molecules come in
contact with water and fat these dual
attractions literally pull the fat apart
surrounding the oil particles and
dispersing them through the water let's
go back to our coronavirus molecule with
that layer of fat holding everything
together when it interacts with soap BAM
that fat gets pulled out by the soap
soap literally pulls apart and
demolishes these viruses and then the
water rinses the harmless leftover
shards of virus down the drain but and
you know where I'm going with this it
takes time for this effect to happen
twenty seconds to be specific to show
why we ordered this lotion that mimics
viruses and their fatty layers it glows
under a UV light
if you just rinse your hands under
regular water nothing comes off if you
wash with soap for just five seconds or
10 seconds your hands are still covered
the virus is still there able to get you
and others sick but 20 full seconds now
the soap is actually destroying the
virus hand sanitizer works too because
it's mostly alcohol an alcohol works in
a somewhat similar way to soap breaking
down that fatty layer you need a high
concentration of alcohol to make that
work
the CDC recommends hand sanitizers with
at least 60% alcohol but even with 60%
alcohol the CDC recommends using soap if
you can if your hands are sweaty or
dirty when you use the sanitizer
that can dilute it and diminish its
effectiveness as for soap just any old
soap works you don't need soap marketed
as antibacterial even the FDA says skip
it there's no proof it's any more
effective just be sure to wash your
hands for 20 seconds that's happy
birthday twice or the course tool is OHS
truth hurts or prints or M&M go or even
dolly just as long as it's 20 seconds
and you're using the ultimate virus
Annihilator soap
[Music]